good evening welcome to the American
Enterprise Institute I'm NAT Malchus
resident scholar in education Policy
Studies here at AEI and I get to be the
moderator for tonight's installment of
our education policy debate series this
debate series aims to gather preeminent
experts on consequential and
controversial topics and engage in what
we wait I have some expert or not yes
yes we have more experts engage in what
we at AI call the competition of ideas
and we often have events that have all
three of those components they have
expertise they have controversy and the
competition of ideas but tonight we want
to take advantage of one more component
and that is the opinions of you the
audience and we're going to do that by
taking your temperature on the motion
who supports it who is against it and
who is undecided going in then we're
gonna have our debate and we're going to
take your temperature again on those
same questions and whoever moves the
most on our motion will be declared the
winner of the debate and of course we
will all win in this if we have civil
discourse over engaging topics so let me
introduce tonight's topic about 50 years
ago in 1968 Demetrio Rodriguez and a
bunch of other parents in Edgewood
school district join together and they
sued in a lawsuit alleging that Texas's
school finance policies were a violation
of the Equal Protection Clause of the
Fourteenth Amendment to the United
States Constitution and they won in
District Court the district court ruled
that Texas's system of school finance
was not not constitutional
but that didn't hold up in 1973 the US
Supreme Court voted by the narrowest
margins five-to-four decision to
overrule the Rodriguez case to let the
Texas school finance system
and there were two key parts of that
ruling that reverberate through our
education system to this day one is that
there is no federal right explicit or
implicit in to education in the US
Constitution and the other one which I'm
going to let the the legal minds that
we've brought before you explain a
little bit more in detail is that at
least as it applies to school finance
poverty is not a suspect classification
you know the effects of this decision
are still being felt 46 years later this
issue is considered settled by some but
there are recent lawsuits in Connecticut
Michigan Mississippi and one that's
gearing up right now in Rhode Island
that is asking the courts to approach
this question again whether there should
be a right to a federal education and
whether it's necessary to fulfill the
promise in Brown v Board of Education
that education must be made available to
all on equal terms now opponents have a
different view they say that actually
constitutionally there is no federal
right to education and no room for it
and besides in 50 states there is a
constitutional right to education and
therefore may be not a need for a rural
role who is right I'm not sure but let's
debate that tonight let me explain how
this debate will pursue I'm going to let
you vote in just a moment on the motion
and then we will have opening statements
going back and forth from the proponents
of the motion and the opponents of the
motion who all introduce in a minute
we'll give them three minutes apiece to
make their opening statements following
that I'll have a period of moderated QA
where our debaters can answer me and
talk to each other directly in crosstalk
as we have a period of debate and then I
will open it up to you the audience both
the audience here and the audience
watching online to ask questions and
again we will allow our debaters to
answer your questions and discuss them
with each other
following those two sections we'll have
each debater give a two-minute closing
argument and finally you'll get to vote
to deliver our decision tonight so we
have a hashtag for anyone following on
social media and anyone who would like
to send me questions that hashtag is
well hashtag AEI debate and you can
tweet me at NAT Malka sand if you give
me those questions I will try and filter
through them while I'm moderating a
debate and get them to our our guest now
usually now is the the time in an event
at AEI when I say please silence your
phones and put them away but actually I
want you to silence your phones and get
them out because we are going to use
them to vote on the motion the Supreme
Court was wrong on Rodriguez there
should be a federal right to education
so here's how we do this on your screen
or on your programs you can see that the
number to text your response to is five
zero seven two six two three two two
zero and I simply want you to text one
if you agree with the motion text eight
two two that number if you disagree with
the motion and do this right now and if
you are undecided that is absolutely
fine you we want you to be decided at
the end not necessarily the beginning if
you're undecided on the motion enter a
three those watching on livestream you
may vote as well again do that right now
the number is 507 to six to three two to
zero
you can only vote once we have a system
to filter out strategic voting and at
the end when we see how far the audience
has moved only those who voted at the
beginning and at the end will have their
votes counted so we really must change
minds to win at the end of the debate
will compare the pre and post debate
votes to determine the winner so vote
now because I'm going to give you about
10 seconds before I lock down the voting
and introduce our debaters all right so
introductions first we have I want to
thank our panel I'll let you applaud in
a minute but we really have some
preeminent legal scholars here too
fate this motion first in support of the
motion Kimberly Robinson is the Austin
II oh and research scholar and law
professor at the University of Richmond
School of Law and a visiting professor
at the University of Virginia law school
she's the author of the forthcoming
volume thoughts on a federal right to
education and she's also the co-editor
of the enduring legacy of Rodriguez
creating new pathways to educational
equal educational opportunity those two
books make her an excellent candidate
for for being here tonight Kimberly you
speak a lot on these subjects I wonder
if you can tell us how briefly how
receptive our folks here in DC to the
idea of a federal right to education so
I think right now we're at a point where
there's been a substantial retreat in
the federal land education and that's
evident in the every student succeeds
act but I do think as we continue to see
disparities in equal educational
opportunity just stares that harm poor
children should have of color
children in rural communities I think
we're gonna see an appetite for some
bold reforms that would address that
issue and a federal right is
well-positioned to be one of those so I
think as we look for solutions to our
opportunity gaps in our achievement gaps
a federal right to education should be
one of those things on the table well we
will see that tonight Ilya Shapiro is
going to kick off to argue against the
motion
Ilia is the director of the Robert a
levy Center on constitutional studies at
the Cato Institute he's the also the
author of religious liberties for
corporations Hobby Lobby the affordable
care act in the Constitution
Ilia provides commentary on CNN Fox News
CBS and other networks frequently I
wonder how often a federal right to
education comes up on cable news I don't
think it's come up but a federal right
to health care came up recently so all
sorts of far-fetched things do emerge
you know Derek black joins Kimberly in
support of the motion derek has a
professor of law at the University of
South Carolina School of Law where he
studies con law and public education
particularly in regard to educational
inequality and before teaching he was a
civil rights litigator Derek I wonder if
you can briefly tell us how far do you
think we've come on educational equity
since Rodriguez well I will be brief I
would say we have come from outrageous
inequality too egregious inequality okay
that is understood understood finally
and and certainly not least Earle malts
arguing against the motion a
distinguished professor at law at
Rutgers law school where he focuses on
constitutional law statutory
interpretation the role of courts and
legal history Earle is the author of
nine books in over fifty articles on
constitutional law Earl you've watched
the Supreme Court for some time I wonder
what are the chances of this court
turning over Rodriguez soon less than
zero okay less than zero audience would
you give our debaters a round of
applause all right we're ready for our
first round of opening statements
opening for the support supporting side
of the motions the Supreme Court was
wrong on Rodriguez there should be a
federal right to education
Kimberly Robinson all right well thank
you not an eye for having me here today
I'm really excited about this topic so
I'm gonna provide three reasons in my
opening remarks for why we should have a
federal right to education i'm sure i'll
provide others during our discussion so
first the court in rodriguez relied upon
the laboratory of the states to address
inequality and spending and educational
opportunity and the court was very clear
that there needed to be greater equality
of opportunity and there needed to be
school funding reform but it said that
the state should be the ones to address
that well almost 50 years later we've
had some improvement as tarik alluded to
in narrowing opportunity gaps
however the laboratory of the state's
largely has been ineffective in ensuring
that all children have equal access to
an excellent education and certainly an
excellent education or high-quality
education is what we want not only for
our own children but for other people's
children or for our nation and it's
critical to to have an educated
citizenry to have an effective workforce
and to have a well-prepared military and
so what we want to understand is that
the states have not provided for
equitable funding here's one point data
point I'll provide on that so Reese
report by the education Law Center
showed that 37 state provide either
equal or less funding to low poverty
districts I'm sorry to high poverty
districts why is that important
researchers agree that low-income
children and communities need more
funding how much more about 40% is the
low end more than double is the high end
but researchers aren't consensus that
they need more funding however we have
37 states that don't provide additional
funding and even in those states that do
provide additional funding the funding
is nowhere close to what researchers say
is needed and so we have a situation
where the laboratory the states has
failed to address the needs of many
communities as well as our nation and we
need to have a federal Romi to address
that so that's my second point we need
those in states where epital funding is
not provided for a high quality
education you need a federal remedy to
address that the state courts have not
provided a sufficient remedy in many
places and in many places they've said
no the state legislature has the sole
control to do what they want and so we
need federal intervention to address
that and my final point is that the
federal government is the sole level of
government that can address interstate
disparities actually the greatest
disparities are between states and only
the federal government has the capacity
the ability and that interest to address
these disparities so for these reasons
we need a federal right to education
Thank You Kimberly Robinson
all right starting off opening
statements against the motion is Illya
Shapiro and I'll hand him his three
minutes now you know when I was first
presented the invitation opportunity to
talk about this issue I kind of found
myself scratching my head because how
can there be a federal right to
education when the Constitution doesn't
give the federal government any power to
regulate or legislate in this area at
all you know when I when I'm asked a
constitutional question and Earl is
going to be the focus in our opening
statements on the constitutional
dimension here for us but when I'm asked
a constitutional question I have this
quaint way of responding by first
actually looking at the constitutional
text and in this by the way is despite
the the Cato pocket Constitution we'll
be able to pick it up in the reception
afterwards you get the Declaration of
Independence included there for free
this is a special Shapiro wedding
edition that we gave to our guests with
our names and the date there might my
wife's a very tolerant lady anyway
article one section eight enumerates all
the seventeen powers that Congress gets
plus the Necessary and Proper Clause you
know whatever it is necessary to enforce
those powers and education is simply not
one of them so this is kind of this
utopian abstraction that we're talking
about in the first place
moreover none of these when we talk
about constitutional rights in in no way
do we generally or normally think about
positive rights that is things that the
government is supposed to give you
rather than the liberty and rights that
the government protects if we establish
either constitutionally or statutorily a
federal right to education well then
what about things that seem even more
important than education food health
care shelter clothing these you know
education is important very important
but these things are probably even more
important so it really opens up a
Pandora's box really the the best
solutions are provided for by federalism
by the the way that our government is
normally supposed to operate and
Kimberly says I
don't dispute that the various states
education policy generally and including
the unconstitutional federal part has
failed a large part of the American
population but bad policy does not
somehow create new constitutional rights
just like when Congress won't act
doesn't mean the president gets more
powers than he otherwise would
similarly bad state court rulings don't
give more power to federal courts or to
again to Congress or or the federal
government if we make this a right to an
education or right to a certain level of
funding a right to certain level of
educational outcomes some sort of right
then this really is a lawyer full
employment Act because you will see
litigation every which way in every
state about every little aspect and so
you know luckily I'm used to speaking a
lot to lawyers and with all of you I
don't have to dumb down my presentation
as much but no offense to lawyers I
really don't think we should have a
lawyer full employment
ladies and gentlemen ileus Bureau in an
opening statement in support of the
motion we now have Derrick black if a
nation expects to be ignorant and free
it expects what never was and never will
be Thomas Jefferson the drafter of the
Declaration of Independence from the
beginning public education has been
bound up in the very idea of our
democracy what a Republican form of
government looks like what it means to
be a nation where the humblest among us
can reach to the highest ranks of the
economy and government office what it
means to be a nation where we can set
our own destiny where those chances are
not a product of one's lineage or
heritage but individual merit and you
can see this in our very earliest
foundational ideas and when those ideas
were put to paper in the thinking and
actions of our first presidents and in
our failures across time you can't see
our national commitment to public
education
our nation has failed to reach its goals
and education far too many times but we
have also read
doubled our efforts after those failures
it is not our failures but our
aspirations that define our commitment
to public education although he was from
a different generation President Lincoln
spoke these truths about the arc of our
foundational ideas speaking of the
Declaration of Independence and the fact
that many people were still shackled and
chained at the moment that it was
drafted he said that the founders were
fully aware that it was not the case
that all men were full it was not the
case that all men were adjoining
equality they meant to set a standard
maximum for free society constantly
looked to constantly labored to
constantly laboured for and even though
never perfectly attained constantly
approximated and thereby constantly
spreading its deep influence that
Lincoln says is the story of equality in
America that I say is the story of
public education in America and I give
you three major points to establish it
in the Northwest Ordinance of 1787 that
set the terms by which all the states
that weren't already part of this nation
that weren't colonies in the nation at
the Northwest Ordinance of 1787 that is
in the front matter of every copy of the
United States code right next to the
United States Constitution right next to
the Declaration of Independence right
next to the Articles of Confederation
the Northwest Ordinance says as a
necessity of good government and the
happiness of mankind schools and the
means of education shall forever be
encouraged seventy-five years later when
Congress was determining whether it
would reinvent southern states after
they had broken the promise of democracy
and had deprived both whites and blacks
of public education and were forced to
adopt new state constitutions and a 14th
amendment Congress readmitted them with
a very specific term that the
constitution of these states shall never
be so amended or changed as to deprive
any citizen or class of citizens of the
United States
of the school rights and privileges in
those state constitutions I'm sorry
Derek that's your time is up but we'll
let you get to your other points in the
further debate and Thank You Derek
speaking last in opening statements for
against the motion rather oral malt so
Rodrigues was based upon an
interpretation of section 1 of the 14th
amendment so in order to answer the
question of whether Rodriguez should be
overruled we have to ask ourselves the
question of what section 1 of the 14th
amendment was designed to do now
education was not a big discussion point
during the debates however there was one
major discussion of in general terms of
what section 1 was designed to do in the
Senate by Jacob Howard who was
presenting the amendment from the Joint
Committee on reconstruction which had
drafted it and Howard made it clear that
the Fourteenth Amendment section 1 was
designed to only protects a certain
group of rights and this is the way he
divided it the rights that were to be
protected were quote those fundamental
rights lying at the basis of all society
without which a people cannot exist
except his slaves any you might say hmm
that might include public education
except he juxtaposes that and says a
group of Rights which are not protected
those rights which are merely the
creature of law and the result of local
or the result of local of positive local
law now whatever one might say about the
right to public education it can only be
the creature of look of the creature of
law the result of positive local law so
therefore under Section under Section
one is not covered now Derik argues that
we should interpret the 14th amendment
by reference to what was required of the
southern states the problem with that is
that some things which other things
which were clearly required at the
southern states were clearly not covered
by section 1 and the most important that
those was the provisions dealing with
the right to vote now the right to vote
was that has a very interesting by Perry
interesting
history and Fourteenth Amendment that it
was imported the prohibition on
discrimination on the basis of race in
the right to vote was actually in the
amendment until the very last moment
when in result reaction to political
blowback in the fear that it would doom
the amendment Congress took it out of
the amendment so that it's not there and
it was very clearly again Howard says
it's not there there was a conscious
decision how that relates the education
point is is the way it relates to
Derek's point about what was required of
the southern states Congress required a
lot of the things of things from the
southern states that were not covered by
section 1 of the Fourteenth Amendment
and with that I'm done thank you for
opening statements from all our debaters
I'm going to the affirmative side bears
the the burden on the first question and
I invite everybody to jump in but I will
start by asking just a definitional
question we're asking should there be a
federal right to education
but I want to challenge you to help put
some flesh on that what exactly does
that mean and and I ask that because
Rodriguez was about funding formulas and
dollars but since Rodriguez we've had a
quite a bit of discussion in education
policy circles on the distribution of
educational facilities curricula quality
teachers and education is such a
irreducibly multi-dimensional thing that
I'm wondering what is the right to so I
think that's would be something that
there would be wide disagreement on but
I think there are some fundamentals that
we could also me to agree upon as a
nation there's some building blocks that
we need for education to be high quality
and it for it to be equitably
distributed so certainly equitable
funding is essential as I mentioned just
additional funding for those who have
greater needs is essential for them to
compete on a level playing field with
their peers other additional necessary
resources include a well-qualified
teacher teachers who are prepared to
equip students with what they need to be
productive in the workforce and to be
engaged as
and so one of the goals I think of
federal right to education would be to
ensure that we have citizens who are
prepared to engage in democracies that's
not only voting it in foreign fashion
but that's also serving on a jury in an
intelligible manner and engaging in the
public discourse of debates but I think
part of what the nation needs is a
discussion about what should each shall
be entitled to but then I think we have
to make a national commitment to provide
it and right now what we provide is the
is the more privileged segments of our
society get an excellent education and
everyone else sort of gets the remnants
of state and local budgets and that is
something I think that must change and
so before I'm gonna ask one follow-up
question then I'll give the opposition's
I had a chance to weigh in and that is
what is the mechanism that would sort of
enforce this right and I'm just asking
because I don't know we have multiplied
multi-dimensional aspects that you've
alluded to which I understand but is
this only in the courts is this sort of
the Department of Education how would we
enforce this so actually this is a the
very question that my forthcoming book
addresses which is how would we
recognize a right to education so Derek
has an excellent chapter on recognizing
implied right to education through the
Constitution I include a chapter about
Congress recognizing such a right under
the spending clause which Congress has
the authority under the spending clause
to act in enact legislation in fate for
the general welfare in addition we have
a chapter I have a chapter in the book
about a constitutional amendment so
there are several avenues through which
you could recognize such a right it
could be enforced in the courts it could
be something that was enacted in statute
and that you engage in a collaborative
enforcement model which is what I've
written about in my work but the point
is that there are multiple ways to get
there it's just important to think about
ultimately what the goals are and how
the goals could most effectively be
achieved response sure first of all
again I'm sorry I have this
predilection to look at the Constitution
when constitutional text is cited but
the general welfare Clause is actually
not a grant of powers to the government
it's a restriction of the powers that
are then enumerated what the general
welfare clause is this is article 1
section 8 for those of you following
along Congress shall have power to lay
and collect taxes duties imposts excises
to pay the debts provide for the common
defense and general welfare of the
United States by doing the following
things general welfare means it cannot
do these things for a regional or
particular or parochial welfare so it's
not that whatever there's a majority in
Congress for which is a representation
of general welfare it gets the power to
do so it is not just an open-ended grant
of majoritarianism in Congress now
everything that Kimberly says may or may
not be solid policy arguments it could
be that states need to change radically
I would argue they should how they
maintain public education I think a lot
of educators are hamstrung by
regulations both from the state and
especially from the unconstitutional
federal Department of Education you free
them up whether through charter schools
other innovations and that's what's
really going to release the the the
better policy so perhaps she's actually
arguing for the constitutional ization
of school choice is that a right that we
have to have more more educational
freedom and that might be a subject for
a different debate but it's been raised
in various contexts Earl Derek I'm just
going to jump in on that sort of what I
would call slightly cramped version of
the general welfare you know if we're
going to suggest that Congress cannot
spend in the general welfare and
education then I think we haven't need
to get another motion up here that
redefines how the court has treated the
general welfare clause for the past
century and we could we could do that as
well but that that motion is clearly
rejected by the Supreme Court for for
quite a long time can I ask you a
question about what seems to me a
central part of the Rodriguez decision
itself which was that poverty should not
be
treated as a suspect class could you
explain just briefly to the audience
what that means and it do you agree with
that yeah well it's complicated with
respect to Rodriguez but the the the
answer to that is that
so if pot but what the court said was
that there if you look at the history of
the 14th amendment but there are only
that there is race and a couple of other
things that are entitled discrimination
the basis of race and the problem that
are entitled to what's called strict
scrutiny the problem with a generalized
holding that poverty is a suspect
classification is that it would
challenge things for example like the
use of fees for all sorts of things and
the court said we just won't don't want
to go there we don't want to have a that
generalized thing and certainly there is
nothing in the text or in the text or
history of the section 1 of the 14th
amendment that would suggest that such
discrimination should be subjected to
strict scrutiny I thought was a
complicated question but that's as good
as I could do it indeed and and and the
opposition I I'm assuming both of you
hold that certainly poverty should not
be allowed as a suspect classification
and yeah which I don't I don't disagree
with what are all said on that I don't
think there's much support for the idea
that there's a generalized hot and
scrutiny but I would say if if
government targets poor children or
actually any group in society just for
sort of animus related reasons even
under rational basis review the court is
going to take a very close look at that
and we've seen that with we've seen that
with legislation against hippies during
the seventies we saw it and Romer versus
Evans with LGBTQ in Colorado that was
rational basis it's just suspiciousness
of targeting someone to harm them but
yes I would agree with one right know
whether it's animus or or targeting or
arbitrary government action effectively
that fails this rational basis test you
hat wearers are not a protected class
but if the government any government aid
or federal passes a law saying anyone
wearing a hat will be shot on sight you
know even that not being a protected
class I think there are some
constitutional issues well let me ask
about this in practical terms then so
just to give a very brief background
Edgewood school district could tax
themselves in a much higher rate than
other districts in Texas but because
they had such little property wealth
they couldn't raise as much as richer
school districts could taxing themselves
at a lower rate this was what caused the
the rub in the Rodriguez case and we
still have that today property tax still
fuels our education system my question
to the opponents of the motion is is the
combination of the Rodriguez decision
and the ubiquity of property tax I mean
does that just mean that our system of
funding schools is inherently
inequitable yeah well there are two
separate questions there's a separate
question about inherently and I could go
in a separate question of unconstitu tax
there are three and a separate question
of what what are we going to do about
those things so you could look at the
world and say that you know it's
inequitable compared would they spend in
Mississippi to what they spend in where
I live in where I grew up in Montgomery
County Maryland for example and one
could imagine even under maybe not I
don't want to speak fairly even under
Ilias view of this taxing spending
clause that maybe the federal government
could give block grants to school
districts which have which are
underfunded that they I don't know if
you'd agree with that or not but it as
taxing or spending for the general
welfare the but then the devil is in the
details and the problem is that once the
federal government starts to have
detailed discs detailed rules about how
the money is going to be spent where the
money is going to be spent the
conditions I knew what it's going to be
spent then we create problems because
schools are not able to adapt to local
conditions and let me give you 30
seconds as an example the I forgot what
it used to be called the education I
guess it's called the education for
children with Disabilities Act
that that be edit the people that one
particular group of people captured the
education and that is the pro
mainstreaming people right that you were
supposed to mainstream people all the
time if you can well it just so happens
that one of my son's works at a facility
for developmentally disabled children
and that just doesn't work for the
mainstreaming just doesn't work for all
a developmentally disabled children the
point being that even if you gave block
grants you would want to give the states
some leeway to try and decide what works
best for them I think it's a
mischaracterization to say that if we
had a federal right to education there's
going to be minut micromanagement of
education by the federal government what
a federal right to education could do is
set a floor of educational opportunity
below which states cannot go and
unfortunately right now we are stepping
on the heads of many children and
communities by providing them in
adequate and inferior educational
opportunities and so the challenge is
what do we do about that and so what the
answer has been so far in our country is
leave it to the States
leave it to the states to figure it out
because under federalism we rely upon
the laboratory of the states to fix
these things however there must come a
day in which we recognize that the
laboratory of the states is failing our
nation and our children and future
generations and then what will we do
about it and so my work seeks to present
not just a federal budget right to
education but just a reimagining of
federal support for high quality
education for all children in which
there's a partnership between the
federal state government it's not that
it's a federal takeover it's not that
the federal government gets to tell you
what time the school day starts and what
time it ends and what school holidays
you can recognize but it is saying that
you cannot continue to provide an
inferior education to disadvantaged
communities to choke communities of
color and to limited English Proficient
of students and that is something that
is consistent with the tenets of our
democracy and is critical to the success
of our economy
let me ask you
about it that was true when Rodriguez
was decided the federal government spent
about 10% of education dollars it's true
today about 10 or 11 percent if we had a
federal right to education this change
that you're advocating for would that
need to change do you anticipate that
the federal government would have a
larger role in expenditures and if not
what would the government's expanded
role be yeah I think it depends on how
you go about this federal right so the
answer is if what we're going to do is
spend through the general welfare which
isn't really a federal right that's just
the federal government sort of playing a
larger role although it may be thinking
that it's doing something based upon a
federal right but it can do that without
the recognition of a federal right so if
it's doing it through the general
welfare then I believe you either have
to spend probably two to three times as
much because you know if I'm you know I
don't know misses I'm not gonna pick up
if I'm whatever state I'm not changed
I'm not changing my practices for ten
percent I mean even Utah I thought about
turning down No Child Left Behind and
they were getting more money out of it
so I think there would have to be more
investment if what Congress was doing
was acting pursuant to an implied or
expressive with the constitutional
amendment in education then it would
have section five powers and it could
demand whatever it wanted as long as it
could get you know a majority and the
House and the Senate and the president
to agree on it but at this moment in
time we don't have a recognized right so
right now the only basis would be to go
into the general spend general welfare
spending clause and that's going to cost
two or three times as much at least but
I will say what you referenced in when
you open this is numerous litigators
have returned to federal court because
of the failure of the states to address
these issues and state courts have not
provided adequate remedies so then we're
going to continue to see this increase
in federal court litigation I agree that
the current Court is not going to
recognize a right to education but I
think there are there may be future
courts that could do so and so we the
return to federal court is an indication
that state courts are not providing the
remedies that communities need
well state courts are better situated to
interpret state constitutions which is
where
most of the rights are currently
situated before we have a federal right
but but regardless as the newly named
chairman of the Advisory Board of the
Mississippi Justice Institute I have to
say that I resent some of the the
implications here I think Mississippi is
up to 48 or 47 on most of the exact
measures but it's not a matter of
funding though is the serious point you
know the best funded school to public
school district in the country I think
is right here in Washington DC in terms
of spending per pupil a lot of the the
highest spending districts in the
country are also the worst performing in
various ways so I I don't think it's
simply a matter of a matter of funding a
lot of charger charter and parochial
schools get a lot better outcomes on
fractions on the dollar and part of that
is regulation and part of that is the
power of teachers unions and part of it
is federal mandates and other things
that are hamstringing the the public
education system no I'll just unveil
that because I used to work for the US
for the District of Columbia schools
when I was Attorney with Hogan and
levels then Hogan Hartson so there's a
myth about how high DC spends it does
have a high expenditure rate but if you
look at research that breaks down how
much is going actually to the classroom
and how much is going to special
education under the idea then you will
see actually that a large poor part of
the DC schools budget goes to special
education particularly to paying for
children to go outside of the district
for services the district cannot
administer so when you take off those
funds and you look at the dollars that
actually go to the classroom you
actually do not have a very well funded
system in DC there are improvements that
are new you know the superintendent's
are working on the Chancellor's are
working but my point is there's this
myth that Oh DC's example why more money
doesn't work but that's an uneducated
view about how DC schools are funded I
have a question about the federalism
question local control is pretty sacred
in a lot of places in the United States
and so to the supporters side I ask is
there value to local control and also is
it at odds with a federal right to
education well I'm gonna break the rules
first
want to say just quickly that crow Bo
Jackson's to this were best study out
there looking at forty years of school
funding data no doubt about it school
funding matters in terms of student
outcomes lawyers Committee for civil
rights Washington lawyers Committee for
civil rights did a study of the metro
area here and showed actually DC was
underfunded in comparison to all the
surrounding ones to your question yes
there is value in local control and I
have always been careful to acknowledge
it I think that that eliminating local
control would be a bad thing I would say
at this point in time though that local
control is has been shrinking because
state power has been growing so we see
local control shrinking regardless of
the federal role at this point and I
think we need we do need parental
involvement we do need local involvement
in that that's a key factor in student
success as well I think the other thing
to keep in mind is that so often we
argue for local control we can't have a
federal district and of a federal that
because of local control however we have
to understand that we local control is
not an end up itself it is a means to
achieve excellence and if local control
is not achieving excellence then we need
to modify that system and engage in a
greater partnership and support from
other levels of government that can help
the locality to achieve its goals more
effectively so let me ask the opposition
to come in it is local control a good
thing I'm not sure what you're gonna
weigh in on that and is it in tension
with a federal right to education it
would be in tension in tension with a
federal right to education but I think
another thing that the discussions of
local control that sometimes missing is
that sometimes different areas simply
have different values and when you have
you can talk in general terms about
excellence but there's also a variety of
different values in addition to this
concept of the laboratories of democracy
and I go back to the IDE a about how it
how it sort of cramped that laboratory
of democracy idea but there's also the
the the idea of different places need
have different values and they should
have some say and how those their
education reflects those values this
ultimately is the
most important point the reason why we
have so much gridlock and toxicity in
our current politics because all major
decisions in all major areas of policy
are pushed up to Washington whether the
Supreme Court whether Congress whether
the executive agencies and for a large
pluralistic society with different
values and priorities and and
what-have-you that's the exact wrong way
to do it
subsidiarity even more than federalism
with if you're Catholic or European
subsidiarity might ring in your ears it
means pushing down decision-making to
the lowest possible level because that's
the way you get the flexibility and
that's the way you you you turn down
tension so it's not Washington making
the same decisions for you know there's
no reason to healthcare education
whatever system has to be the same in
California and Ohio and Florida and
Virginia so quick question of the
supporters before we move to audience
questions and if you have a question I'd
encourage you to come up to one of the
microphones on the side and offer that
up in just a couple of minutes here but
one of the questions that has come up
briefly is that an excellent education
system is a prerequisite for
participating in our democracy and and
so forth and I I want to ask to develop
that line of thinking and if that is
enough to establish a right to education
or a theory there and just how you
construct that argument yeah I mean I
think some of my friends get upset with
me because I really do limit it to
citizenship and that doesn't necessarily
include stem and they're like how could
you talk about a right to education it
doesn't include stem and my answer is
because my understanding of the
education that our democracy demands is
one that prepares for citizenship not
for computers with that said I don't
have any fear that somehow another we
would have a bunch of schools that were
excellent at preparing citizenship and
didn't care whether they learned math or
not so I mean yes I don't include it and
my core concept but that doesn't bother
me as a practical matter did I
so I'll ask one other question because
I'm allowed to go I'm the moderator
there's you know there's a question and
even in our in our motion that the
Supreme Court was wrong on Rodriguez
that there must be something in the
Constitution to have a federal right for
education is there another viable route
to establish a federal right to
education and what would that look like
either side can take that so I
definitely think that Congress could
recognize a right to education under the
14th amendment through section 5 I think
that's also possible I think that it
could approximate something similar to
right through the spending clause as
well so I think Congress definitely has
the authority in fact there have been
numerous pieces of legislation that I've
gone through have been proposed in
Congress but have not been successful
that have tried to establish that -
right but I do think there's I mean
there's a full body of scholarship as
well not just on Congress records so I
think that - right but also implying is
that the right in the Constitution so I
think there's a you know multiple
avenues where how it could be recognized
there's a mom Congress can pass a law
all sorts of things and that creates a
right of some sort of the statutory
right courts have to evaluate I think
that against the Constitution of course
but it depends on whether you're your
right is you know worth the paper it's
written on so I don't know exactly how
that would well you know how that would
look but sure Congress can pass a law
saying you have a right to XYZ well I
might just repeat what John Powell said
about a decade ago which is really a
critique of Congress there is not a
single thing that needs to be done in
our schools not a single thing that
Congress cannot do tomorrow because it
does have the resources to do it chooses
not to so regardless whether there's a
federal constitutional right or not
Congress is complicit in its failure to
spend to address our national interest
and it has been complicit for quite some
time in that respect
because because we have such a surplus
in our budget I think just a couple of
airplanes would cover it actually
so let's talk about that spending and
I'm gonna wait for folks to line up at
the microphones before I turn it over to
you for questions so please come up on
either side
Derek you mentioned that we don't we
would have to spend a lot more it but I
also wonder in in the context of No
Child Left Behind other federal reforms
it's arguable that just with actually
the same ten per spent ten percent of
spending that the federal government
administrative Lea has been able to get
a lot of the changes they want to see is
that a viable route in your eyes towards
some of the the ways that we could
improve equity without actually invoking
this sort of federal right on equity yes
well I should be me I'm gonna say
something that might surprise some folks
we got a lot of Education change during
the Obama administration for a very
little bit of money and I think that
Arne Duncan overstepped his statutory
authority and doing so in fact I argued
that even if it was in this statutory
authority I believe was unconstitutional
so I won't go into all those reasons why
but I do think there are limits to what
the federal government can demand in
exchange for money and that sort of
changing of the rules I think school
funding is actually simpler in terms of
what we're actually asking you to do but
it's a much bigger lift for the states
and 10% will not buy that from the
states if I was a state governor I would
say no for 10% no I'm not going to do
that yeah and part of the concern
actually is that what we have right now
is we have this very limited 10%
investment in education by the federal
government but the federal government
still asked for quite a bit at least
under No Child Left Behind it it rolled
that back quite a bit and that every
student succeeds Act but this is a very
flawed model of federalism if you were
going to ask for much you need to also
the federal government needs to be
investing much and that would be a much
more effective model for federalism if
you're going to be demanding a lot from
the states particularly you know more
equitable funding then the federal
government's got to be willing to help
do the heavy lifting for making that
happen Earl Ilya responds before we go
to audience questions all right so I'll
take audience questions just line up at
either side there is a small thing I'd
like to remind you that a there's a
difference between a statement and a
question a question at AEI is a sentence
a single sentence and it ends in a
question mark if you could give a
question to our panelists just give us
your name and your question yeah my name
is Colin slowy and I was kind of
speaking to or asking a question based
on what the opposition said about
different areas having different values
and different concepts of excellence um
I was wondering could you I speak to
what impact intellectual diversity so
like diversity of viewpoints and in
educational backgrounds whether that's a
good or bad thing for American society
and how that might impact what we mean
when we say equal education intellectual
diversity is a good idea
absolutely it is and this is part of the
problem with having you know one size
fits all state schools it's that you're
gonna gonna be getting kind of one one
perspective on things
but yeah intellectual diversity is
really can answer that question yeah
yeah diversity is a good thing but I was
gonna say the the sort of idea of
different values I guess we could define
what that mean I don't think that
communities do have different values
when it comes to a quality education I
think the fact that we see so many
children running from public schools to
be quite honest in places like Detroit
and New Orleans is not because they have
different values than some suburbs it's
because their local district lacks the
capacity to serve them they're willing
to go anywhere they can get a better a
better deal they think they can but then
ironically they get there and they
switch through three or four more
charter schools their desire at enormous
numbers as the same desire that other
communities have they just lack the
capacity to access the resources that
they need question from the left side hi
I'm William Turner and this questions
primarily directed towards
professor's Block in Robinson a lot of
the time when we are having these
discussions we think about outcomes in
education and I wonder how much of that
we should attribute to classroom funding
and quality of teachers versus some
things that have nothing to do with with
government like parent and student
apathy language barriers gang violence
in the communities to what extent should
that oh should we think of that in terms
of how students succeed so that's a
great question there's there are
certainly some things that a federal
right to education could help to help
address fundamental foundational
building blocks for the next such
education which I've mentioned some
funding high quality teachers access to
a you know wide reading curriculum
however there are some things that if
federal right and the federal government
itself cannot you know directly change
however there there's definitely
significant research that shows that a
high quality school can do a lot can
make a big difference in communities of
poverty addressing some of the issues
that children bring to the classroom
many schools are sites for social
services and other things that help to
support the challenges that children are
facing and so while certainly a federal
right to education would not be a
panacea for the ills of the nation
unfortunately United States we don't
have an adequate social safety net to
address many of the ills of our society
and so one of the challenges has been
that our schools are forced to be the
locus for trying to address those issues
so a federal right would not be a
panacea for those things but could
certainly help to lift the floor that
right now is very low opportunity to
respond you need not where schools
aren't supposed to be social service
providers and all that you know fix the
other just just because you know other
parts of our public policy might be
failing whether order federal or state
level doesn't does it mean that that
schools ought to pick up the slack you
know unless they fail at all their
missions that they're given I think we
have about time for one more over here
on the right
yeah hi I'm Scott um I was wondering
whether there have been cases where
because of like functional illiteracy on
part of a failure of Education someone
has actually been not been denied this a
jury jury service or anything similar to
that because you mentioned that in the
beginning Marko Rubel has done a lot of
work on jury service and particularly in
New York City and so yes there there's
one argument I haven't made it Kimmel II
may have made it that actually your
ability to get a jury of your peers is
substantially compromised by our
education system because you're many of
your peers are excluded from the jury
pool based upon their lack of education
thanks for your questions and I'd like
to have a round of applause before we
move to our closing State
in the same order that the opening
statements came we'll start with closing
statements from Kimberly Robbins
great so I'm actually gonna be very
brief because I made my points
throughout the debate I think the
important thing that I want to leave you
with is this we are in education reforms
tinkering at the margins of Education
opportunity we come up with a great
charter school here and we come up with
a new teacher training program there and
we you know develop some other reform
that catches everyone's attention but
what we are doing is moving chairs
around a ship that is ultimately deeply
flawed and so we're not going to get to
our ultimate destination of a well
educated citizenry a robust economy and
a well-prepared military unless we
change the very foundation upon which
our education system is built and so
definitely I believe strongly that our
federal right to education is one way to
do that I think it also requires us to
reimagine our relationship between the
federal and state government I don't
think we need to fear federal
involvement education when it seeks to
promote equity and excellence and so I
think we need to really re-examine what
we are doing and to stop sacrificing
children and communities at this altar
to state and local control we have to
come up with a bold reform to get to an
excellent education for all children and
I believe that a federal right to
education is one way to do that closing
statement in support of the motion from
Kimberly Robinson and now in opposition
to the motion alia Shapiro I still don't
know what a federal right to education
means even setting aside my qualms about
the government's federal government's
involvement in this area in the first
place constitutionally but is it simply
a right to more money you know
equalizing that is it federal regulation
of teachers or federal regulation of
school yards you know I I don't know
what that means but even once you get
past that point why do we think that
involving the federal government will
necessarily make things better rather
than more convoluted and stifling
innovation you know that we have there's
I'm not an education Skol
no means I'm a simple constitutional
lawyer but it seems to me that you know
education policy scholars ought to be
working at those grassroot and and and
local and state levels to improve
education policy I don't know what the
federal government has to do if
someone's violating your civil rights in
terms of discriminating against you
based on your race or your religion or
something like that I mean sure take
that to federal court but I don't know
what a federal right to education would
mean other than lawyers suing over every
little thing and really not getting
anything done in the first place in
terms of these excellent outcomes that
we all want closing statement by Ilya
Shapiro and now to Derrick flags in
support of the motion I'm not gonna give
a closing statement I'm just gonna
finish my opening ones so so ninety
years after the Civil War when the
Supreme Court issued Brown versus Board
of Education it said that today
education is perhaps the most important
function of state and local government
it is required in the performance of our
most basic public responsibilities it is
the very foundation of good citizenship
we can debate and play with the various
different ways we want to interpret the
Constitution but there is but one single
story of education and this nation's
commitment to it across time and isn't a
story where education has always been
understood to be the foundation of our
democratic and constitutional
commitments they're black and finishing
today for our closing statements Earl
Maltz you know I share some of his
qualms about the content of the federal
right to education because now I can
certainly imagine a situation where the
federal government as I said would give
block grants to both public schools and
frankly to private schools to deal with
to to develop better educational
programs what I fear about the federal
right to education is what we have seen
in a wide variety of areas that we end
up with micromanagement from Washington
and these very lots and lots of
litigation that doesn't produce much
good outcome so as I said I can imagine
the federal government providing more
funding but I worry about micromanage
and I'd like to invite everyone to join
me in applauding our debaters tonight
[Applause]
now is the time for a decision I'd like
you to follow the exact same process as
earlier the phone number to text to make
your final decision on whether you agree
disagree or still undecided with the
motion or now undecided could be the
Supreme Court was wrong on Rodriguez
there should be a federal right to
education the number is 507 to 6 to 3 2
to 0 please vote now both online and
present I'll give you about 30 more
seconds and you're gonna text a 1 if you
support the motion a 2 if you disagree
with it and a 3 if you're undecided
weighted we're on hold give you just a
few more seconds again the number 507 to
6 to 3 2 to 0 and I'll give you about 10
more seconds and then we will tally our
votes all right I'm gonna give it just a
few more seconds I'm gonna ask the the
for a little speculation from our from
our debaters now that they no longer
have to sway your decision let's just
stipulate that that Rodriguez for the
moment was correct and and that there's
also a statutory path forward for our
federal right to education which do you
think is the most likely of these two
paths that the Supreme Court would
overturn Rodriguez or that a statutory
right to a fund amount a pull some right
to a fundamental right to education
would be passed to take a statutory
right is much more like always better in
Congress trying to aggrandize its own
power yes I I don't I think that
interestingly even the sort of culture
of constitutional law has moved and I
think it would be even if there became
got it to be a progressive majority on
the court I suspect that they would be
unlikely to overrule Rodriguez because
it's become so deeply embedded or not
constitutional and it would open a
Pandora's box I think that they would be
hesitant to pursue it but a statutory
thing is possible supporting side I
think it statutory right it's much more
likely then I think regardless of which
branch does it
I would just say it's quite remarkable
how comfortable states have gotten with
the federal and education
notwithstanding the fact that I wrote
abandoning the federal and education
recently but generally speaking you know
they've they've gotten use to that
federal role and so I I think it would
be a far more politically palatable okay
so we can end the debate on something we
can all agree all right I think we have
a decision here and while Connor Kurtz
here is delivering I'd like to thank him
because he did all the yeoman's work of
putting together this debate so if we
can ever okay so is the winner law all
in it is not it is not here we go
round one the initial votes 57% of the
audience agreed with the motion
supported the motion 17% were against
the motion and undecided was 26% in the
final vote 64% of the audience agreed
with the motion that's a gain of 7
points 7 percentage points and that's
the number to beat for in the second
round of voting voting against the
motion 30 percent of the audience
gaining 13 points and the winner is the
up of the opposing side tonight in our
debate thank you very much for coming
please stay to talk to the panelists and
our other guests and have another drink
outside thank you again
[Music]